because yeah someone asked me if they're
like you're doing it by yourself is it
what the [ __ ] i was like i would never
we got a team you have to be a real
sociopath to do tough mudder do
something yeah by yourself dude
the thick boy crew yeah mark
callan you
uh we have a bun but literally a bunch
of people run casey we have a bunch of
people i think my buddy i think my best
friend's going to be best friend big j
does he start with jobs
coming from start with that's going to
start with a with a long run see it's a
different trail i don't know what i'm
sure it's lake elsinore that last one
you start off with
pretty big hike oh
but but you're not running like you're
not running you're just hiking you can
run people will run but i jog
i jump walk jog walk yeah we'll talk i'm
not going to run a chatty cathy on that
yeah hike it up we'll hike watch your
people it'd be fun man but you so you
officially
i officially signed up i've never done
anything like this ever in my life you
need to get out of your comfort zone
yeah it is yeah i'm gonna wear
apparently look at me right now i'm
gonna wear a pair of jean shorts now
listen oh
tell me about it jean shorts oh good now
you get tired yeah you take let me see
your index finger yeah you take that in
the next one
rump no you take that anything and you
loop that in the back of my belt oh your
you just follow my little skinny hips
yep and i'll take you around the
mountain follow that little trick i
trust you okay so you just i feel like
we'd be at the same pace maybe you'd
probably be quicker than me
i'm an old man
i see his feet he's not known for his
partner
your feet is what i'm nervous about
you know what i'm nervous about yeah
what's the weather like during that is
it gonna be freezing i don't do well
with the cold i'm i'm a coward run well
in the gym
i'm told you should wear tights and
maybe uh i didn't okay but he just you
just wore shorts shorts on the tv you
got some thick skin your ding ling was
i think i saw a picture of you like and
i'm not saying i'm scared of this
i saw you swimming you swimming [ __ ] you
got to go underwater yeah oh there's a
cold plunge
really
chin if you go to the
the tough mudder website they have a
special cause yeah i saw a mudder
link so there's a limited amount of
thick mudder uh spots so if you list
this now we are almost full yeah okay i
know so if you're going to talk somebody
sign me up right now please can you go
there and sign me up
brian so here's the thing so chin if you
go to um
trying to think if you go to the 15th
okay
then it should say
15k
because we don't [ __ ] around
keep scrolling down
no no go go up choose your adventure
wanna go back to events here i'll give
you the link
i'll give you the link send the link
yeah i'll send them later it's easier
hey brian so like if you know just that
you know just the situation yeah i'm
stuck in the water yeah drug water yeah
what are you gonna do you're not
swimming so what i do is i jump in
there's no swimming
i i grab you around i go so i reach over
your shoulder and grab under your
armpits so okay now i do side stroke and
i take you right to the [ __ ] shore
you [ __ ] the whole time going shh hey
i got you just stay buoyant stay buoyant
okay stay buoyant and listen to your
voice yeah stay buoyant stay boring you
might fall asleep don't worry about it
i'll pat you awake and then we [ __ ]
there it is uh yeah
okay i trust you i trust
my feet fall off i'm going to jump on
your back and you're going to take me
there come on yeah i got good feet
that's right and then and then not to
borrow your feet the best thing is that
at the end they have all these food
trucks and coffee and whiskey and you
get a cool if you finish i'm not saying
you guys can finish you get a wait tough
mudder
shirt that says i finished 15. look at
me there it is wait wait why wouldn't we
see that's that's the water right there
and that's where it shocks you now what
are you doing there bubba would you and
mark what do you do you guys yeah what
is it what is this teamwork meet each
other and you gotta walk across this
thing and you fall in and say that's me
and brian that's you and brian okay
brian that's you and jay you probably
want to you want a thicker guy you want
to think about it me and casey and
whatever we might have partners now it
says join brennan chubb and the thick
boys for 15k tough mudder what is that
there what is that that thing if you
fall in it's deep water and then you
gotta swing across so this is where i
saw you swimming square scroll down how
far so that thing you get in the water
and then you need teamwork because it's
all about teamwork
and you gotta you gotta pull over to the
other side to get over so so so those
two people on the bottom push
those two people on the oh i'm cheating
that's a [ __ ] book
that water wasn't that cold i think they
might heat that one but the people on
the bottom push and you got to come over
you're probably like five feet you look
like you're dry humping that [ __ ]
yeah no i'm hanging on for the ride were
you helping that guy out or something or
trying to no no i was well they need to
push me over and then i get on the other
side and i help them you look like
you're looking at the guy there going
i'm gonna [ __ ]
that's what it looks like i am cheeked
up right congrats everybody you've
earned it so if you want to run with
chappelle brian a bunch of the thickies
all you got to do is go to
toughmudder.com
thick with three c's and you'll see the
sign up there make sure you sign up for
the thick one now you're gonna have a
thick boy shirt for me yeah i i have
some thick mushrooms it seems like
there's a lot of teamwork activity
that's and then you see in the back
there the the rope thing that's probably
the toughest part that that wall's out
yeah
crawl up it all right now let me ask you
this that's all teamwork really teamwork
yeah now now um you're the the thick boy
mother shirts are they do they cling to
the body are they made of a synthetic
are they like a rash guard do you know
they're built daddy they're built uh
thick boy mutter shirts okay so i don't
need a tight shirt underneath that that
hugs to the body no you don't need that
last time i surrendered my thick boy
built shirt the black one you still wear
shorts the white
yeah but now here's the thing i don't do
well in the cold too i don't mean to say
life beater if it's if it's cold she
look at the weather right now in lake
elsinore now last night was the coldest
recorded uh night in la in like 40 years
oh so it might be a weird time to look
yeah it's been real it's cold out here
but but now it's like 68 degrees outside
i know oh jim why is it bringing a bunch
of times looking for a ring for your
girl interesting yeah what's up no this
is actually for you uh well i'll talk to
you about it after the show oh okay all
right so uh why are you trying to yeah
yeah
you saw that actually for a long time
what's the date so if it's the 29th it's
66 degrees that and that's like elsinore
they're predicting 66 that's perfect
yeah that's not bad okay no that's not
bad at all not bad short and too far
outside
good and it's not it doesn't really get
cold up there i may have 66 it could
even be 68.69 san diego yeah
a lot of crocodiles in lake house a lot
of crops really a lot of crops
there's a lot of cougars a lot of
cougars a lot of cougars a lot of older
ladies with money huh
oh cougars out there so don't bring so
don't bring your your bear spray was
that a real is that a real rich area
i've never been to lake elsinore neither
you know anything about it i have no
idea where it's at no i'm just going to
play this no it's two and a half hours
away head down there yeah we should stay
the night before we should we'll do that
hotel stay night before you guys do that
carb up a little bit right yeah carb up
sure day before get some of those gel
packs yeah what what did you eat at the
top of the morning uh i didn't eat i
don't eat breakfast
that's why when i got done with it i
would now i probably made a mistake
because daddy was cramping i started
cramping at the end there
but then i ate a full foot long hot i
deep throated that hot dog so fast i was
there
i want to yeah maybe i won't eat i don't
know what time do we start 10 a.m i said
reasonable you want to be there around
the good house
but i mean i need at least something
yeah if you always eat breakfast you
don't want to run on full stomach though
no i do not because then your body is
breaking that down instead of giving you
energy to complete the course yeah
think about it
you know
you don't want you don't eat like i
can't believe i really can't believe i'm
doing this
really yeah my i told my family they're
shocked really they're like what the
[ __ ] are you doing it's great like you
don't do anything like that's the whole
point yeah that's why you're doing it i
didn't know what i was getting to either
and i [ __ ] loved it dude but you kick
ass with [ __ ] like this i guess that
thing was a different answer no matters
brennan and i did a sort of a mini fight
companion this morning we do it's called
the cowboys fight fan classic it's on
the super cats only can video and audio
where we watch uh say like francis and
ghana has a fight coming up we'll watch
all his fights but the first one we
watched my fights and that was really
fun because i hadn't seen i i realized i
hadn't seen those fights in years
like i forgot about how you were
actually you were actually legitimately
beating crow cop in every round that
that was not down every round well no
you were also giving in the what for
controlling him yeah you were giving him
the what for and you were the most you
were the aggressor and he was playing
defense the entire time yeah he's a
counterpart popping him with that jab
you know and he broke your nose but that
was that was one elbow but for the most
part did a lot of damage for the most
part for your the the in your fights
fighting monsters like gonzaga and crow
cup and those guys who had that much
experience daddy didn't get much of a
mark on it
beat the brakes off and didn't i yeah
you did you really did you're timing
your timing on the takedown was
unbelievable i told you my favorite
johnny curtis that's my favorite fight
of yours i love that damn he loves the
johnny curtis the really fast one oh no
he's like a minute seven yeah i got set
up it was my second fight ever
and my manager at the time you know some
scumbag was like oh i gotta fight for
you you want to fight out of town and at
the time like my team all of us were
just coming up we're like yeah we'll
fight out town be cool man like yeah you
go to dc and fight my god be so cool so
they signed like three of us up to fight
in dc and i'm like who am i fighting
though like dude it's just something
like
he's an older guy he has high school
wrestling easy fight for you he's a
cakewalk you know you're still building
so we want to be a cakewalk we're
weighing in and i'm like i don't see any
[ __ ] heavyweights where's my opponent
man we're waiting then we hear this
when this [ __ ] dude rose up like sons
of anarchy on a big hog american flags
flapping and the crowd i'm like where's
the crowd or they start going johnny
johnny johnny i'm like johnny that's my
[ __ ] opponent just this big
dude gets off the bike and he's all
johnny curtis how you doing i'm like
holy [ __ ] and then we do research on
which we didn't do before this because
we you know we thought we were just
gonna kill him just have yeah well he
was a high school wrestler he was on the
national wrestling team oh no he was the
wrestling coach for george mason
university
he was four-time all-american he was i
think did he go to the olympics he no
never went dylan he was 4-0 and i'm like
oh they're set me up and i was so mad
and you see it in the fight because i
absolutely
wrecked his entire world because he
didn't know how to box like you you know
he just wanted to wrestle but he
couldn't get daddy down at first so then
i hit with a left hook from [ __ ]
pueblo colorado
and his knee buckles tears every
ligament his knee but he can't fall down
because his leg is stuck and i go he's
not going down there's no ref i'm gonna
[ __ ] punch him straight in his old
face i punch him in the face he goes
down there there he is legend
look at that that's a big fella big
mother he's he as tall as you
yeah oh yeah yeah his but i don't like
his boxing stance
all he wants i think he just got hit
right there yeah oh yeah he gets knocked
out right there yeah 404 so then uh he
blows every there here you go here's the
[ __ ] fight
you might have i was like why say 10
minutes though yeah probably intro yeah
the intro look let me let me hear that
let me hear that
it's probably me talking [ __ ] remember i
was young hungry lying i'm not hungry at
one point when you knocked out what's
his name you've dusted your shoulder off
oh this one's funny colorado uh i fight
of tcao out of denver colorado um
trainers either are trevor whitman and
christian allen you know what it's uh
it's
bodied up
i'm ready for anything i think that's
like
like still wherever uh
um
if he wants to keep it on his feet you
know that's definitely in my favor he
wants to go the ground that's fine too
uh when the fans leave on saturday night
they're definitely gonna be saying wow
he's the next big heavyweight i love
that kind of confidence uh and this is a
confident young man
luke thomas was the announcer on this oh
[ __ ] exhibiting a lot of maturity that's
sort of been the theme tonight here this
is
five-year-olds
now you're nervous here but your cough
is super difficult very large i might
add six foot six i'm not six inches
25 25 years old you're 25 here fights
out of a good school look at the holy
spirit that needs the most work and
he'll be the first to admit this
he needs experience in there he's got
the maturity he's got the same they
didn't walk out with you no he's a
little more look at christian allen now
christian allen who's behind her he's a
ninja and he's a genius yeah he's he's
corey san hagen's main main that's luke
thomas talking right now right first of
all he's only been trading boxing for
six months and because he could tell us
him
six months six months strength and
conditioning coach that's the ufc
welterweight champion george st pierre
has trains at high altitude there's
christian allen see the guy that's right
yeah
marshall in the back genius shane carwin
luca dio cody donovan dwayne vayne
how about luke thomas
he's great though he had him hung out in
the locker room before so you gotta
remember this guy fighting with one
spirit martial arts out of wrestling
virginia that's a wrong strategy i'm
saying some guy with my hands up that's
an all-american man right there
i will throw some on the feet that's a
ben ice cream that's a giant basket
right there
in freedom tree service and so it's
physical but i train six days a week uh
outside of that you know so i i feel for
being 38 years old i feel really good
his wife and kids were in the front row
man
handsome guy though handsome guy at 38.
we're in right now a real man a real man
just adored here by everyone phenomenal
wrestling yeah you hear that adored here
by everyone pretty good submissions
what'd you say who's elvis that's a big
elvis who's the big elvis guy
take him out forward a little chin up
take a minute are we allowed to show
this i don't know
i'll show like little pieces like big
guy there's some paper
all right
now i said six four i'm one and now see
there but there's
go gosh look at you dog
his opponent on my left fighting in the
red corner
hometown hero right there this is a
[ __ ] crowd
for god's sake oh he's the coach
yeah he's the head coach
in the blue and black trunks john curtis
in the olive that was when when neck
tattoos were still rare
mix it up here real rebel mike king
getting ready to get the heavy weight
started
the question is two thousand keep it on
five feet i think this is just gonna win
this organization still exists here no
no
i think the owner of this organization
organization he's looking to take you
down he didn't have a box now that's all
he wants to do is get me down all right
i want to be at the end of the day
you've been boxing for six months i'm
like i'm happy with that oh oh boy oh he
picked you oh he's oh damn daddy got
back to his feet yeah you did yeah good
shot though oh yeah great shot about
shot
defense oh
all right very good balance watch out
balance hard for him to get off luke was
in his basement oh
good that was the inexperience i pulled
him right on top of me he hurt when he
felt his back he was right in front of
us in the back of his that's luke young
luke thomas back there uh-huh he's a
strong kid though watch this though
watch daddy now
this was my move
now now he's in trouble
now daddy's in trouble
see he wants to take down but he
he's not saying that with his punches
he's very now he feels how strong you
are i think here he's strong no he's
very strong and he's a you can see he's
a better wrestler he's gonna do what he
wants to set up those takedowns though
very aggressive he's a young aggressive
kid
out here watch this i'm so yes
i'm very upset i feel like they're
trying to set me up brandon
crowd was not happy
yeah you knocked out their hometown hero
almost down here
he's 38 you got it you can't you can't
be fighting now i think i killed josh
barnett and frank mayweather i was very
look at his [ __ ] knee oh yeah he's
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] he called me
schweinsteiger
hey look at what look watch what i see
rewind it he says schwab watch i go
[ __ ] even back then i was pretty
pissed when they missed my name but just
watch my face when they say brendan
schwab
stop this fight one minute and sit like
seconds look i'm looking at my thumb
why not watch this
[Laughter]
people still call you schwab that was a
very yeah a good demonstration uh taking
out a very tough tough fighter uh key to
this one clearly take down defense you
had the knees going you had the hands
going uh you wanted nothing to do with
the ground you wanted to demonstrate
your hands in this one it looked like
uh yeah i did but you know i'm
comfortable wherever it goes if he wants
to go to the ground that's fine so i was
comfortable down there um it's just
really wherever i want to take it your
face is different
six
career here with the win this was your
pro debut tonight what can we look
forward to and
josh barnett uh next slice at the end
there nice uh theatrics there what can
we look forward to uh just bigger and
better things only up from here and uh i
appreciate the uwc for what they did and
it's just bigger and better things from
here look you'll see a lot of me now
here's the end of the fight talk us
through this brendan
i went for a double leg look like i
stuffed him gave him an uppercut his
knee he was out then and then one just
to make sure a couple more
just to make sure
the way down
but you're doing what a fighter is
supposed to do you guys stood over him
the referee tells you otherwise good job
finishing
yeah you know that's what we're trying
to do is finish it till the ref pulls us
off so uh me or not you know dude it's
so interesting how youth hey bright
future look at how skinny his face
the los angeles is face for a
heavyweight and a small head yeah uh
luke thomas has interviewed me before in
the hotel and he's like so what's next
i'm like you know i'd love to get my
hands on frank mayor josh barnett and
tom's like okay how many fights you have
like
one well i i think after looking at your
fights i i also think you were in a d
you were at a time when you know a lot
of those guys just weren't the athletes
yeah no they just weren't even now
without yeah even out because you're
your strength and your speed you know
you were just a football player this is
very different and i think you've been
training
the way they had been your whole life
higher level you're training at a super
high level yes you kind of knew how to
train without getting injured maybe you
knew your body better
that was your pro debut
they say that we're really my bro
i got paid my on my i never had any
amateurs i said pro debut but my first
fight was like 30 seconds long that ring
of fire and broomfield went out
i forgot did you get did you end up
getting the cat for tiger
what happened
you know there are a lot of new year's
resolutions dude get in shape and stuff
dude what about save some money on your
prescriptions we're getting older we use
prescriptions why why don't you why why
not why not save some money do it with
good rx man do it with good rx listen
prescription prices can vary between
pharmacies as much as a hundred bucks
but now i check goodrx compare prices of
pharmacies near me we're talking cvs
walgreens save yourself up to eighty
percent eighty percent good rx is free
and easy to use works whether you do or
do not have insurance even if you have
insurance yeah dude that's a good chance
good rx can beat your copay price you
can check good rx online or on their app
which i suggest it's a great app and you
can find prescription savings at over 70
000 pharmacies nationwide like cbs
kroger walgreens rite aid bonds walmart
and so much more so for simple smart
savings on your prescriptions check good
rx go to
goodrx.com slash fighter that's good rx
dot com slash fighter goodrx.com
good rx is not insurance but can be used
instead of insurance in 2021 goodrx
users saved an average of 79 on retail
prescription prices boom get rx.com
you gotta you know you spend most of
your life sleeping you know this i mean
at least a third of your life and if you
don't have a good mattress what are you
gonna do you are going to pay a price
helix mattresses that's all i have in my
house and i can't get people to leave
once they sleep on that once they sleep
they just want to stay there dude they
sent me the perfect bed i'm a side
sleeper and what i did is a helix sleep
they got a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete they match your thick ass body
with the exact mattress built just for
you everybody has their own sleep
preferences and they they narrow it down
yeah they do so if you're looking for a
great mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress that you're matched
to the mat just comes right to your door
softly shipped off me [ __ ] hard free
dude yeah you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store ever ever again all right
so just go to helixsleep.com fighter
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
were
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 and by gq and wired
magazine helix has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution for improvement improving sleep
they have a 10-year warranty and get to
try it out 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will so don't worry
about it helia give it a 200 dude 200
off felix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows two
free pillows finer kid listeners and
viewers at helix sleep.com fighter
that's helix sleep.com fighter cooling
technology
i forgot did you get did you end up
getting the cat for tiger
what happened
what no hold on you got allergic you
bought a cat
and you and you returned it the next day
because you were sneezing i know that's
exactly what that so
oh my gosh so you brought you buy
something so i needed i need a hyper
allergenic cat right i got to get those
no they're not cheap daddy they're not
cheap so i go online and type in best
hyper allergenic cats and like 10 cats
there's only 10 in the world and only
like one or two are actually
non-allergenic so i was like all right
cool
found the name put the name in the
russian blue
the russian blue yeah they're [ __ ]
they're amazing yeah so i go to this uh
that's where you put it go the website
chin for me you put in russian blue
russian blue so
bunch sites pop up yeah but i need a i
need a male uh i want two cats yeah
right so
uh we go to russia there you go russian
blue kids for sale right those are
[ __ ] cute there dude now it says all
the russian blue kitties listed below
for sale are home raised by us all of
our babies come highly socialized health
guaranteed okay this is great i'm in
reached out to him you got nala you got
kitty sure ten weeks sure sure and we
got racks so we got racks okay and then
uh my girl goes so they need 800 you
guys send a cash up i'm like that's easy
and i go have you talked to him she goes
i'm texting with him and uh he says just
send the 800 and we the cat's ours i'm
like all right she goes
they said to make sure somebody's home
at 9 00 am tomorrow at 9 a.m where
where's the breeder at she goes oklahoma
9 a.m so they're gonna fly through the
night with the cats i don't like the way
that she's going well she then she goes
that's that's what i said and the guy
goes yeah we do it all the time this is
what we do okay cool they do and they're
here they do
so then i'm thinking in my head why
can't
the one cat's gonna be scared flying
alone i'm gonna you know i'm gonna get a
sister no i gotta stop you now hold on
no
she was talking to me he said we'll have
the cat the next day yeah
a little bit right but to me i'm like
you got to buy the ticket well to me i'm
like well i've been oklahoma
yeah the flight time i guess they do it
i'm not i'm not i'm never about to kill
you you know yeah so i go i don't want
the cat flying by itself so me it's
gonna be scared it's a good one he's a
friend and tiger wants two right look at
kitty yeah so i so i got foxy and we
name it we have names for them names are
rip and beth from yellowstone of course
right so they're they say so he sends me
this picture of the cat is this him
right now dude he can't wait am i kill
yeah
now in his text
the english is misspelled whatever it's
like all right maybe he's texting fast
so like tonight the night goes on the
night goes on right so hold on i've sent
sixteen hundred dollars at this point
six hundred dollars
six o'clock
i tell my girl go hey did they give you
uh anything on shipping they go yeah
they're using i forget the shipping
thing i go okay and they get in and she
goes i just got a text i just got text
from him look at this show me the text
english is off again the spelling's all
incorrect yeah it goes hey we're at the
airport now the crate that we're sending
on doesn't work they're gonna freeze to
death we need to get this other crate
it's two grand wire's two grand and then
when the cats land we're gonna keep the
crate because you won't need it it's for
flights only and we'll give you your
cash back so it's just a deposit
so i go
hey
hold on so i go
huh and joe goes do you i don't know it
seems kind of fishy you think
so i look go online go scams how you
know you've been scammed number one
thing is when they go hey we need this
money for a crate there's their go-to
crate and then also n house a huge red
flag it's a scam if they say they can
send the cat the next day because those
cats
you're writing months for a hyper
allergenic cat
they're not available because people
with allergies yeah so you got to wait
for a litter which is what we're doing
now so you wait for a litter so first
red flag is a they can send the next day
be there for more money so listen this
isn't a russian guy's bank account yep
so listen to this so i so i look it up
realize scam see a guy in reddit go hey
did anybody else get scanned by what was
the website blue blue russian blue
uh bluebell russianblues.com
complete scam do not use them so i
realized that scam on the thing goes
they're going to try and engage with it
as much as they can to get money out of
you so i go well i'm have some fun with
this
so daddy goes hey man
hey man love once i knew i go because
joanna was texting her give me your
phone so i go hey man love the cats dude
i'm a huge cat guy
now i think about it can you give me one
of these and i [ __ ] screenshot a
giant bengal tiger like a [ __ ] adult
like wild from india i go do i'm really
thinking about getting one of these can
you fit one of these on that thing that
i just paid two grand for i didn't send
him money i go i'm saving the money dude
but how much would be something like
this and he puts no problem obviously
it's just a hustle and i go how much is
this bengal tiger dude like it's gonna
be crazy for me it was not too much let
me talk to my guys and go cool say last
man he was all right let me check on it
for you minute goes by he's not
responding so i go dude you know what
man now i think about it three cats
ain't enough i said well i would like
now i need
the two original cats i paid for i need
the bengal tiger you have to put on the
same shipping and these guys these these
two might not fit so let me know how
much is shipping on these things i send
pictures of
some pictures of two white tigers from
vegas
and i go all right bro we're looking at
we're i go we're looking at five cats
total here three of them are live tigers
i go do you know do you know what type
of food i should feed this thing do you
think kibble and bits are getting done
he's entertained he's like well the dry
food literally and all broken the dry
food might work man you're gonna have to
figure it out i can't i don't have too
much experience yet i go on let me ask
my uncle i said uh my uncle's very
familiar with cats i screenshot a
picture of joe exotic with two cats
i'm going to talk to my uncle and i go
this is him he might know him he just
goes radio silent after that
it's silent so
we got hustled
super hospital the first red flag should
have been we're gonna hear this piece of
[ __ ] out so it's uh
russian blue bells whatever it is
so
bluebellrussiansblues.com they're the
ones who create a whole scam right and
so i call him
so the so this is the first red flag
again this isn't me this my girl takes
on them
his cash app is money signed y26013
toronto amended fischer yeah that's not
his real name it's this game he's
probably in south africa yeah he might
be in toronto no no no i did a research
on his cell phone but he uses expressvpn
so said district of columbia sure but
they're just scammers they might be in
india yeah they could be anywhere so i
sent the cash up cash up you can do a
thing where they have been scammed
someone way back they look into it they
might so i might get the money back but
if anyone knows any hyper allergenic
cats that are available
in the next three months let me know i
need two for my [ __ ] son dude
my son he's so i've never heard more
exciting his life he's at jiu jitsu the
other night stops the class tells the
class oh tomorrow my dad's getting me
two cats they're hype the rip and bath
he goes dad you have your phone like
dude we're not doing oh and the kids
gather around like here's the cat my
girl my girl has the cats as a
screensaver
no so he's like i'll be at school but
dad dad you'll pick them up right i'm
like i'm gonna pick him up dude at this
point
at this point i know it's a hospital i'm
like
at this point all you're thinking about
is is that you're just thinking about oh
dude
he put their beds in his room he's like
they're gonna sleep with me every night
dad blah blah blah now
what um can you go to a breeder around
here it's hard we haven't those hyper
allergenic cats we haven't found in
california if it was here i'd drive down
there i'll pay extra if anybody knows
any hypoallergenic cats i will pay extra
give my son a [ __ ] cat yeah he's so
broken hard so i might be able to find
him so so my girl
my girl found a legit breeder a legit
breeder are you are you still trying to
get two though oh yeah my still want a
tiger yeah i still want that bengal
tiger how about he was entertaining but
my girl uh she found uh she's like said
something on her instagram story i guess
and people reached out and they said the
number one breeder for those cats that
you want are in indiana and that the guy
was like it's complete scam anybody with
any of these specialty cats they're not
gonna happen for four to six months like
they're not it takes a minute because
yeah if they do have litters then well
first people the people are waiting six
months you're calling so we put a
reserve down on these two but i told my
girl i'm gonna say something on the show
there's people with actual
hyperallergenic cats don't give a [ __ ]
what breed let me know i'll drive down
there and pay whatever you know what i'm
going to do
i'm going to order some cats from this
guy and i'm going to have a long text
conversation without you you're never
going to get them no but that's a self
right there if you want yeah that's what
i mean is i want to i want to i'm going
to on the website i'm going to call
whatever and i'm going to say but he
could probably switch that number up oh
they're i'm i i'm surprised website's
still up because once i realized it was
a scam
you know and then once i did the whole
uh joe exotic [ __ ] and tried to get
tigers from him
can you believe he entertained that yeah
i'm going to have a long time we're
talking about food how much they eat how
to ship what are you going to say so
that's the number on the website that's
the number no that's his number
405-293-8708 that's a scammer's number
okay legit scammer and the people
they've scammed people before
my girl goes uh because i start i go you
had i said you had you had rip as your
screen saver i started laughing and i
was like and i go this is funny to me
she was how's this [ __ ] funny you're
out six hundred dollars i go because
i said hey it's a great story b i'll be
able to make this a bit so i'll get my
money back selling tickets on the road
sure b it's gonna be fun content for the
podcast and i said and uh and c
we're so fortunate where to a lot of
people sending that money they would
[ __ ] wreck them
to me i'll find another one this guy
i'll get the money back hopefully i
catch up if i don't we're so blessed man
that we're that this doesn't affect us
yeah i said you're looking at the wrong
way that says and i said also it's
hilarious i said it's hilarious you got
hustled and alerted
and i told who gets hustled by a [ __ ]
cat guy so and i looked up online it's a
real problem for puppies especially in
cats but only the high level puppies and
cats only the ones like everybody wants
these specialty uh dogs tigers broken
heart say the least bit but we did uh
facetime with the breeder and he showed
us his cats what we're getting and
there's no way that your girl is going
to settle for a dog
yeah because there was i tried i dude i
tried she just doesn't want to take on
the response like catch his plug and
play she'd get super attached to it she
she doesn't want to have to pick up [ __ ]
and like walk and she just she's swamped
dude which i understand yeah i
understand i get it i get it i talked
wrong about cats too he told me the
troubles about it but it's not his time
but at this point
no he give him away no no i mean
he called me one time this is when we
were really young oh yeah back in the
day though not that he killed his cat oh
yeah not because he has ragdoll kittens
now i don't think he has anyone else
yeah yeah he's a rag dog they're cute as
[ __ ]
yeah they're super cute yeah i have to
get cats now though tiger's broke you
have to get cats i show them pictures
that helped
okay
that's a rag doll yeah that's
hypoallergenic no they're not people
think they're there's actually only two
breeds that are actually hybrid
and we got two of them
in june
they're coming in they're coming in june
they're not born yet
and now june for a five-year-old well
it's eternal forever yeah well that's
forever and by the way he's forgotten
about it by then because his heart's
already broken in half oh no
this morning drawing cats right in the
dad we're still in the club
we gotta see him before we name him yeah
and you don't want him to turn into a
joe exotic so what we want to do is clip
those wings we don't get them too into
cats yeah no you don't want to be cat
guy yeah but when you're a kid you don't
know like he doesn't know he wants a dog
but i see his mom's a [ __ ] hater you
know yeah well one of the memories he
did all the searching for it
like you didn't i'm not putting all the
blame on her i found that website
because it popped up and i sent her
but she should have known when she
talked to me
he talked like this yes yeah i help you
with your cat i hope you guys they're a
fun cat i said
i sent you pictures now i sent you and
he sent us the pictures now if you just
take those pictures that belong to
google you'll see that to copy and paste
they're on a ton of scans you can do
that oh yeah okay upload pictures oh my
god it's such a hustle that's funny
they got us you got scammed with the
detailing of your uh
four by four i remember a long time ago
she got scammed once again she got
scared she got scared wait no it's not
it's not her fault no
because you you're not gonna trust how
do you most of the time you don't get
burned and sometimes you do yeah i don't
know why she do anything this guy this
guy had a whole website though this guy
was oh no this is all they do they make
hundreds of thousand dollars doing
support i mean it's [ __ ] up dude go
after that guy i don't know who's gonna
go after yeah they're all they get they
get a lot of elderly with scamming [ __ ]
dude they almost got my my mom sent me
and jay she goes hey they say my iphone
account's gonna get deactivated if i
don't pay this she supports me the email
you go mom just click on the email you
click it so it says apple but you click
on the email it's like
yzzrusha.com like yeah apple that's not
their website that's not their email
handle she's like oh i'm like it's a
hustle mama
my homie got scammed out of 5 000.
really yeah because they linked to their
they knew he was with chase i don't know
how they know this like
yeah i think it's like
very little information that they need
they call it the bank you don't you know
the biggest ones that the irs hustle so
it's not that so just so you know taxes
the irs will never call you if they ever
pretend they're the iris irs the
government does not call it you get a
letter in the mail and you'll find out
that way do you know what i call them do
not call it i called them just not just
for shits and giving i know it was a
scam and the guy was from india and he
goes like this as i i literally go hey
how much do i owe
yeah i'm nervous it's better
[ __ ] [ __ ] your [ __ ] your mother
your [ __ ] and just
it was great
i was like in a great indian accent you
[ __ ] got me yeah they got us damn
it's whatever for me but for myself yeah
i need to find two [ __ ] hyper
allergenic cats stat you'll find them
we'll see hopefully some but that
doesn't make a lot more sense it does
take months for you know and make sure
that they're hypoallergenic you know
make sure that they're like what was
that we talked to we talked to a guy and
he goes a lot of people are going to say
they're hypoallergenic there's two
actual cats that won't cause you
allergies he hates the two he sells one
of the two and it's not the blue the
blue russians we got a different cat now
he's real fluffy but no allergies no
shedding well our boy frank willow
decided to buy two coney corsos they're
all over his instagram
now i don't know if you know this they
get up to a hundred and twenty pounds
but he we're sitting there and he starts
to realize that these puppies are a lot
they're a lot oh they're all the work
and hit but here's the problem here's
the problem his sons
have fallen in love with look at there
they go now his sons has fallen in love
with both dogs so he says i've realized
two dogs is too many
i got to return one of
them the breeder calls the breeders no
problem i get it i'll give you i'll give
you the and so he's got the dog and his
son is holding the dog yep that's now
that's a puppy no i don't have his ears
frank yeah whatever no they did he
didn't the breeder yeah so now he's got
the dog right and his i was right there
his son comes out he's holding the dog
and he goes listen we're going to give
we have to give that dog back we're
going to keep just one and his son looks
at him and goes
his son goes absolutely no that doesn't
work for you they get to attack yeah he
goes that doesn't work for me and frank
goes what he goes that's not going to
work for me
and frank goes well then you got to
watch the coolest fight now he's got two
times get so big oh bro
guess daddy went to the dentist
yesterday my girlfriend how'd it go so
did i i was there too let me tell you
something man
i when and i lied to them they go when
does that start with a dentist say oh 10
years my girl goes brendan you got to be
honest here i said probably more than
10. she goes well just give us like a s
15 years let's call it she goes oh wow
this can be interesting
yep yep yep it's gonna be interesting
she goes you're gonna be here a while
it's probably gonna be pretty painful
okay that's cool when i say i was
nervous i told my all of them were in
the room like doing that she text me i
looked at my girl go i would rather
bungee jump in mexico right now yep
because i hate max so i hate bungee
jumping and it's super dangerous people
die all the time yeah i go i'd rather
bungee jump in mexico than do this right
now shake your shoulder man i got a text
from you it's just a dentistry and you
go [ __ ] did he go to your guy no but
he's going to no i'm going to now dr so
this so so i sit there they're doing
x-rays and i'm like it's gonna be a
[ __ ] night man i better have 90
cavities
they're doing them they go once this
time saw dentists about 15 years she
goes huh and they were they're hoping
daddy had a [ __ ] up mouth yeah
nope no
one small cavity and it's from the crown
that i got 15 years ago i had to recrown
it so remember it's black before yep
daddy's white now and did they and now
here's you with that wonderful that
wasn't that fun to have that needle
stick your so
the needle i was too he brought the nail
out and you got medieval [ __ ] tools
dude like they're not friendly looking
they are doesn't it
i told my girl you got medieval [ __ ]
tools like you turned me into reek you
didn't get the reference to game of
thrones and i go i go dude you can't get
a friendlier looking needle and tools he
goes what he's like armenia he's like
what i'm like whatever when he did the
needle i was like had to close my eyes
but they pinch your cheek and then pull
it yep and then i didn't feel it at all
my mouth is just the right side's numb
yeah he go if that didn't hurt at all
because that don't hurt right we're
about pain free here i'm like oh thank
god so they do they he he does the crown
didn't feel a thing i'm like oh i could
do this all day this isn't bad and he
goes now buddy the cleaning's gonna hurt
you haven't been in the dents about 15
years you got plaque the clean's gonna
hurt i gotta go below your gum line
bubba yeah bro yeah bro they gotta
scrape he had
he had the touch yeah of a [ __ ] truck
i was like you're gonna break my [ __ ]
teeth up when i say the cleaning hurt
because when he goes when he's doing my
cavity when he's fulfilling or pulling
the the thing in he goes if there's pain
lift your left hand okay didn't touch i
didn't have to lift it during the clean
i kept going like this he goes oh buddy
that's just for the cavity for this
you're gonna lift your left hand your
left foot doesn't matter i have to clean
them
it hurts so [ __ ] bad man i will
exactly i will because he's getting the
nerve he's getting the root there's a
nerve there here's daddy's problem is i
apparently i grind my teeth that's not
when i sleep during the day i didn't
know that i paid personalities when i
work i grind right now
i grab my teeth it must be me i lie my
dentist just said something i always
tell type 8 personalities you guys grind
yep so my gums and my uh the enamel on
my teeth yep so i don't have cavities
might you know i can't eat sugar
sensitive it's because i grind them down
so much they're sensitive to cold and
hot and sugar so what are you are you
gonna have to cap them he says we don't
have to do anything right now he goes
you have to do anything okay and i like
i like that dennis he's not trying to
hustle you no he said you don't have to
do anything but that that the the teeth
cleaning that and because it's so
sensitive when they're scraping down
here it's so sensitive
i tears in my eyes now my girl's
laughing like laughing at me it's a
taste of blood huh there's blood all
over my mouth
my girl's laughing her left you're the
one that got hustled by a [ __ ] cat
scammer
that didn't go over well in the dental
office she walked out that's whatever
and i wanted to walk out i was so upset
i go dude there has to be a better way
to do you floss a lot are you very you
do you have no floss at all floss
were floss the other day he looked at me
am i a baby
hold on real quick he looked at me
[ __ ] crazy hey this is the best part
you know it's important
it's really important yeah
because that's how that's how you get
below that yeah
yeah dude not doing it how about this
how about this when when he goes oh wow
your teeth for not being under 15 year
pretty good and my girl's oh you
shouldn't have told him that and he goes
well look let's book your next next
appointment and i go i'll get back to
you and she goes we better see i know
you when we walked out my girl's like
god i wish they didn't tell you that and
i looked at my girl well i'm never going
back yeah she goes you're going back and
go no you don't understand that hurt ten
times worse than i thought you're my age
it's tough oh dude when it gets to the
point where i can't chew i'll go back
okay for now
correct [ __ ] off dude correct that the
way you hiding
there has to be a better way they kept
looking at my chart and she kept going
she kept going
to it was 2018 was the last time you had
your teeth cleaned i go it is it is it
is and i'm a very bad patient we know
this i went through the whole motion
with the invisalign did i wear it no i
didn't i just i'm terrible with the
dentist i hate it but i i broke my tooth
i broke my tooth now daddy's teeth from
cleaning are [ __ ] clean man oh yeah
but your guy has a light touch my guy is
probably the best
so first of all when they clean you that
way they're supposed to do just one side
then you come back for the next side
doing the whole mouth like that that's
insane after you haven't had a cleaning
that long that's right but so he does
the one side that was numb yeah and he
he's like i'm doing the other side and
it's going to get pretty dicey here yeah
i'm like what the [ __ ] dicey mean
because my teeth the enamel enamel's
worn out dude dude i could feel the
shooting pain up my face that's so awful
that's so there has to be a better way
to do this it's got to be a better way
and then when they leave them he's all
right that's it buddy he leaves and then
you know the dental assistant comes in
she's polishing her teeth on like [ __ ]
you
i don't want to pause
and they're already [ __ ] aggravated
from yeah [ __ ] now you don't want any
invisalign huh because now all they do
is they scan it they scan your mouth
well you know what they told me
so he goes he goes uh bite down for me
he has to marry his bite down bite down
and he goes your teeth are so most the
time the the bottom go under the front
go like sure
yours are exactly like this oh you're
like a bulldog
no i don't have a hundred bites i don't
have an overbear yeah yeah they they
they line together
so you see how yours see how you're
about to hate to put my feet though so
yeah like mine hey sorry i'm so sorry
there you go
see see how the top or uh above the
bottom that's how everyone's buying of
course mine's not let me see
i didn't know that
that's interesting i thought they're
supposed to line up of course they are
they're not it's like your ball one ball
is supposed to hang lower than the other
you know why so they don't clang
together so yeah so you have one ball is
always lower your top teeth are supposed
to cover and like protect the bottom
mind your mind line up surface so the
invisalign not for you no so he wanted
me to go to orthodontist and get some uh
he referred to him as braces and uh i'm
supposed to crank it to widen my mouth
because the roof of the mouse is going
up and it's running so he goes can you
breathe out your nose or you'll never
never have been able to he's like cause
that's because your teeth
what he's like your parents never took
you to they would have spot this right
away like you've had this your whole
life oh way to go mom and dad oh no so
now here's the problem when you look at
the dentist and you open that can of
worms they'll look at your mouth and go
well we got some issues here and then
you're like you got a choice you got a
choice well choose like do you want to
schedule over their donuts
that's two years that's a three-year
process by the way you want to grow your
mouth out yeah that'll be three years
yeah see you there yeah i'll be there
what's the address again yeah yeah but
it's not full-on braces it's just like
no it's like these side clamps and you
gotta turn and it just helps the office
is on the clock no way and never yeah
but you don't you don't you don't
struggle with like you don't have like
sleep apnea no not at all you don't no
you're sure i don't snore none of that
okay i sleep great
jesus so it sounds like you're you're uh
i will never be back that cleaning was
the worst experience of my entire life
through your nose right now
oh you got blockage
i've always had it though yeah since my
nose surgery yeah so never going back
that cleaning was the worst experience
of my life but my girl goes it's not
that bad i'm like you don't understand
but brendan again you're the one who got
scammed by cats it's horrible she also
goes to the dentist every six months
probably she used to work at one tiger
and the kids go every [ __ ] like three
that's what
so originally because i had to they
didn't finish my cleaning because they
they found like a uh cavity that fell
out or whatever so they had to like
really fill out yeah yeah so they had to
refill it or whatever and then it's
still a very manual
cleaning and i i just love it yeah i
like to eat but i hate going out all the
time oh it's the worst dude
dude i mean is there a grub hub we got
shows tonight you want to go home and
cook a meal no i don't do you want it
brought to me dude we got you covered
man you don't need to take a break from
your gaming or your favorite tv show
you're bingeing you get sent straight to
your crib with grubhub that's right
grubhub guarantees guarantees you your
food will get you on time within the
delivery window for the lowest price
compared to other apps well they're
working or you get back at least a five
dollar in perks that way you can
experience your food just like the
restaurant and 10 did man grubhub loves
restaurants all right order through the
grubhub app or online grubhub we serve
restaurants baby you're doing the thick
mud or it's january 29th i need some
energy yeah dude i need i i don't want
to break down do you have any advice
yeah dude you need some on it
supplements because you know daddy's
joints are gonna be hurting so we got
joint oil krill oil all right
you need optimized mental space to get
up those ladders just like that
that shroom shroom tech alpha brain i
suggest alpha brain black label heavy on
the black well look they got total
strength and performance they got
protein powders they got all kinds of
stuff but i think that shroom tech sport
for me i swear by it i'm all about alpha
brain black label they got the focus
shots we got protein powder if you're
doing the thick mudder you want to
recover how about you get a little
hungry while you're doing that 15k we
got freaking warrior bars protein bites
we got coffee for your ass early in the
morning to get you right to the thick
mudder what are you doing we got fish
whey proteins they got plant-based
protein we got fitness gear to prepare
you for the thick mudder january 29th
set up right now make sure it's the 10
am thick boy thick mudder at 10 a.m
but if you're getting in shape for that
dude use their home fitness programs
they get on demand workouts battle ropes
get your thick ass in shape we've got
kettlebells steel maces club maces we
got it all men on it.com
fighter for 10 off sign up for the thick
mudder right now as well that is january
29th get your thick ass there
yeah oh you know what i want to get tell
me what you think of this beat now it's
not
it's not uh
dent dentures hold on
um there it is
fake teeth yeah
yeah veneers veneers it's kind of a
veneer but it's just the front cap let
me show you this your teeth
yeah we got we got are you a top teeth
straight it's just his mouth is growing
wrong and pretty soon he's going to be
it's going to be a disaster i'm going to
die yeah
he's going to die from bad mouth that's
what i want to do but but daddy you
don't floss that's my face never yours
are pretty straight brian yeah i'm a
good looking kid though yeah a lot of us
genetically yeah
teeth teeth are genetic yeah good as
long as you don't see my bottom teeth my
bottom teeth brush these are a nightmare
look they're all fighting no that's not
bad i know but daddy's got to get the
only ones like cooking i'm going back
i'm going back to the invisalign your
bottom teeth now i didn't create this
name for this game when i was a kid but
your bottom teeth are playing somewhere
like where yeah your bottom teeth look
like a rugby scuffle yeah that is so
this is what daddy wants to do so they
just do the front they don't do the so
don't have to shave your teeth okay look
at that all right look at that that
could be me dude that's it you want that
that's called the video that's what i
want that's a video it's a veneer but
it's not the full and it'll bond to your
tooth too yeah bond yeah so they just
got to take the enamel off the front and
then they they don't shave them down so
it's basically like a grill here's the
only problem with that
sometimes for whatever reason the gum
gets black the gum dies a little bit
look at that hottie yeah it could be me
dude you can also tell it's a fake [ __ ]
though
well of course yeah even even theirs
you're never like
you got to pay a lot of money for a
veneer so that they have the coloration
those are 30 g's yeah but what i want to
do wait this thing is why i'm bringing
it up is i hope this doctor sam
salad
here's this is like dude
let us hook you up if you post about it
i'm like no problemo dude give me the
white grill yeah because that's the
other thing the dentist gave me the
mirror goes you think he was talking
about my bike you see any problems with
it i said my teeth are brown and that's
a problem yeah
well i i think before you do the veneers
you may have to do a little bit of
adjustment it might it might it might
require i don't think so so i'm just
gonna keep keep on keeping on now and
now you're not a dentist so i don't need
you to say i don't think so because we
don't know yet but yeah
but what if i just want to leave it like
this because i don't care about
breathing on my nose and just have white
teeth because you're because your bite
would have so when they do that they've
got to measure your bite as a whole
factor for sure yeah and right now your
teeth are meeting so if they make that
big they're not meeting that's the
problem though yeah if they if they make
those teeth bigger it's going to be you
brushed two times a week it's going to
be lit uh once a day just in the morning
you don't have two times a day nope and
that's why daddy doesn't have cavity so
i don't brush no i do the same thing for
a lot of times you brush slices
yeah
they keep brushing twice
three times a day and you're like you
know when you when you're hustle from
crest bro
they're hustling yeah they want to use
more toothpaste because your mouth has
its size
if you eat well your mouth has its own
sort of way of dealing with when you eat
it cleans your teeth actually i i can't
believe you only brushed once because i
i only practiced once in the morning at
night no dude you only brush at night
dude i've been brushing in the morning
just in the morning oh just somebody
just haven't brushed my teeth at night
in 30 years dude i knew a guy that only
brushed his teeth at night
well that's well his breath smells like
[ __ ]
during the day yeah it was disgusting
you got to brush your teeth i cleaned
the [ __ ] out of my mouth in the morning
but i go hard in the paint that one time
is harder than the but a lot of times
almost always at night i'm like you know
what time for bed yeah i just don't have
him daddy wants to go night night yeah i
might floss if i got [ __ ] in my teeth
that i can feel otherwise my girl goes
crazy on me if i don't brush my teeth at
night tell her to relax tell her the
hustle tell the christmas oh i'm going
to tell her hustle yeah brush your teeth
well here's the other deal but here's
the other thing
so a lot of people a lot of people wash
their hands after they piss okay
i'm saying it makes more sense
i'm saying it makes more sense to wash
your hands before in the real world
before now you're touching your dick
correct because my dick's not touching
you shaking hands doors you got
influence on your dick the whole thing's
got it science clean your [ __ ] hands
look at this never sick great teeth
never go to the dentist how long do you
ever see me sick you go to the dentist
outside brush your teeth twice a day yep
yeah i like good teeth well all right
all right
i'm living really good well y'all some
weirdos wash your hands after you piss
when you get a little piece on your
hands why would i it's my dad
i'm gonna tell you why are you peeing on
your hand
accidentally just [ __ ] i don't know
i won't wash my hands i won't wash my
hands after i piss it makes me angry the
people me too please wash my hands
jump in guys
no i just thought he put his finger in
your mouth
i thought of that too that's all i can
think of okay brush your teeth again
right now
what the [ __ ] dude
get the [ __ ] out of here and you know
what i'm not not i'm not that guy who
like scurries out he's gonna watch his
hands i want everybody no oh yeah he's
gonna wash his hands i'll go me too wash
your hands cool man not me brendan i
noticed that in the airport whenever
we're in the bathroom or whatever i'm
like this [ __ ] walks straight up
now you know the old saying is you don't
wash your hands after your pee it's like
i don't piss on my hands
you know what i'm saying bro but also at
the same time you're touching all that
[ __ ] in there you're watching
the gals i've ever been with dated have
always brushed their teeth after every
meal including lunch and i'm always
doing it i like to floss after a meal
all right you know whatever what was
wrong with you you got great teeth i'm
not gonna lie keep doing what you're
doing man waste your life waste my life
you probably you probably wanna kill me
how many people wash your hands there
after you piss
by the way
chin does your girl make you wash your
hands no
dude by the way i remember walking not
not in this building but in the mauka
building you guys would like to go to
the restroom together i saw piss in the
freaking sink and i'm like at this point
there's no way i can get near the sea
i'm like i don't know who did that i
grabbed paper towels
i don't know what you're talking about
the door too because i know you guys
touch your dicks and touch all that [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying yeah i got to use
people
you're like the hell's angel when i'm
wasting trees
but hey my girl that she always says and
you're texting while you're just oh well
your balls and your dick are permeated
over they're perfect yeah they're
perched like they're hanging over a wall
and i got black jeans on somebody barely
pulls his pants out he doesn't have the
energy he's like there you go
let's pull this whole thing out and it's
just sitting there perched so now that
his dick is kind of pointing forward as
he's [ __ ] he's just texting that's
just it's probably touching the urinal
too
yeah sure or whatever dude my girl gets
so offended when because she'll rush in
the bathroom to pee it's late at night
and i get a p2 i'm not waiting first i
piss in the scene my own scene it's my
thing
[Music]
well that's gross as long as you don't
wash your ass in the sink which i would
never do
you've done that it sounds like you've
done that which i would
i would never do that even though i need
a clean whistle at all times
bro that was the reason why i wear dark
undies you feel me there you go
i mean you piss in your own sink it's my
sink but but
that's gross but why how's it any
different than the toilet
piss isn't that good
because because that's not what the the
sink is
hey bro hey is tony falci live with you
oh god dude [ __ ] it
get your comment here
did you uh listen to
dr malone on rogan's podcast and it
would make you you're playing a little
bit yeah crazy bro crazy everybody in
the world should listen to that guy
because well they are rogan's downloads
are around 30 40 million compared to fox
oh yeah which are around two to three
cnn doesn't even break a million rogan
breaks on average 11 million
i don't know if you saw that no i don't
know
30 million bubba 30 million 30 yeah
three zero and and and cnn cnn is do you
have that article change and by the way
all of that is
senior citizens homes airports
and i'll tell you the graphic jim okay
it's unbelievable that that this is how
we do
that guy's a true scientist who's at the
front lines of the biodiversity and they
kicked them off of uh social media so
you know rogan went to that uh the
g-t-y-r-r or whatever he's like
he's like twitter's just getting crazy
if they decide kick me off i'm going
here and 300 000 people followed rogan
over there what's the gtr it's like
getter or something like that gtt er
it's a thing that uh
someone that was in uh
uh house started well he went over there
well you got
pro trump i mean this is a lot of like
you know obviously
he's just doing precautionary so if they
take him off you can at least have a
voice i love how they they line them up
with marjorie taylor green i love how
they and they say it's right-wing
they're just [ __ ]
they're such [ __ ] wait what
oh who's that cutie on the right
wow on bravo i love you all says look at
that vest that was with danny cohen you
[ __ ] with vest hell yeah you're talking
about your uh roger where roger thanks
for talking about
so what's going on with getter can we
can we get on there like you can it's
just a virgin of uh version of uh
twitter but different so
people think it's for the right like
there's obviously a lot of writing a lot
of q a on there a lot of just you know
it's social media
founded by jason miller well yeah more
than 170 000 people have joined getter
since rogan's announcement wow yeah and
then they'll they'll look they'll say oh
this is a far right thing instead of
people who just want to
speak their mind
so is ghetto claims his purpose is
fighting cancel culture while creating a
true marketplace of ideas
there appears to be limited moderation
on their site so far the platform has
already welcomed scores of far-right
users including uh q and on conspiracy i
mean yeah you're telling me [ __ ]
those idiots and and they've decided
what what is misinformation and what's
not and i think what's interesting
actual scientist is this guy who's who's
not only a scientist the leading one of
the leading authorities sir he created
the coven 19 vaccine when he's getting
the vaccine he goes
he goes i don't boast he goes but i was
like i created that and she was like
what are you gonna get a selfie with you
he said i created this vacation and all
he's doing is pointing out conflicts of
interest with pfizer that's what i was
getting yeah he's oh you're right about
11 million my bet so joe rogan 11
million on average tucker carlson who's
the next biggest is 3.2 the five also
fox 2.9 hannity fox 2.9 fox news
obviously fox 2.3 uh ingram angle fox
rachel maddow
rachel maddow is a 2.2
she's for cnn 0.8 yeah
well they suck they're terrible they
they lie
and how great is this
cnn nbc abc news uh purposely avoids a
lot of very important stories like the
hunter biden uh laptop thing sure like
that conflict of interest because it
doesn't fit their narrative they
absolutely they absolutely what about
the guy who crashed in those innocent
people yeah but because he's black it
it's they don't know this race right
that was it yeah doesn't even cover it
no they don't they won't cover it what
about the written house trial correct
how crazy is that yeah
already saying that he was a far right
sure he's not at all so what happens is
they lose their credibility
um you know
well they don't have trump to pick on so
then nobody's watching what they also
yeah i mean i don't want to get into
this [ __ ] because we'll get flagged but
we'll let me let's be very clear here
there are certain things i could say
that are science right now i could say
there are science
and you're also definitely a band
because you're not scientists and
yeah no but there are certain things i
could i could
parent what's that
and we would get flagged so so if you so
freedom of speech is not alive it is
gone and unless you're on super cast
subscribe right now
give it up dog super cast super casual
super cast super casual super cat but
that's what's gonna happen the people
it's about time getter and these other
platforms come along well you need
someone like [ __ ] mover and shaker like
rogan to go over there and people like
oh brogan's on here yeah now frozen when
i'm just on here would really splash the
waters but nice
i'm surprised twitter haven't hasn't
banned rogan yet
well he's it's kind of it's coming he
doesn't say anything but just because
what he represents i'm surprised those
soy boys
he represents the truth he has very
smart
they don't want that no because it hurts
their bottom line because the amount of
sort of the
the parallel uh conflicts of interest
between big tech big media farm big
pharma you know big business just how
everybody gets everybody's getting a
piece of that pie when it comes to
vaccines yeah things it's really
interesting that's probably that's right
and also the media also their business
model is based off clicks not truth so
when you get the scare of omnicron and
stuff like that that's what leads the
ratings you've watched cnn who's tanking
like a [ __ ] you watch their
ratings it's all fear of omicron
vaccines they had the death count they
had the death count like that in cnn how
crazy is that jeff zucker
made that uh thing but the me but that
works for a lot of people that fear and
people are scared to go out i cancelled
all my tour dates in january we're
rescheduling rally because this stuff
because that that that works and hurts
people that go to live shows or you know
concerts stuff like that movie theaters
it hurts the entire business but because
they they're motivated by fare it hurts
it hurts touring comics man especially
in blue states so i re
i'm waiting for omni crown which i think
by february thing's gonna be a lot
easier so i'm just doing spots around la
we got our sold out show tonight at the
improv so holler boys let's go rally i
rescheduled
this weekend wise guys wise guys
tomorrow thursday friday saturday we got
a total of the five great club man get
your tickets i can't wait club
i can't believe people are coming i was
so nervous that people weren't going to
not salt like we did all right
the height of the pandemic and they were
out i'm talking the beginning when we
thought it was they come out
now you had a snowstorm in raleigh so
you had to cancel that oh well raleigh's
fun because you have winter advisory so
uh our flights were canceled they want
to rebook them that's a good time you've
got omnicron you have school shutting
down you have businesses worried it's a
perfect storm so i went you know what
this makes no sense for me to go out
there not to mention again it is what it
is i'm not anti-vacciny fasting your
boy's vaccinated
my grandma who's had she got uh
modernist got both shots she was fine
with that she got the booster last week
and now she's on the her deathbed
yeah now she's the exception she's also
98 yeah but she got the booster and that
you know it's gonna kill my it's gonna
kill my grandmother
it's gonna kill my grandma and so once i
found that out i was like man i gotta i
gotta this fight i'm gonna chill out in
january i'm gonna wait for this this
media thing my grandma i'ma chill out
yeah my mom has covey so you can see me
around la i'll be doing spots at improv
and comedy store she's good she's 80.
yeah my dad could give a [ __ ] 81 como
bridges up the ass he's like man
whatever she's like i'm trying to sleep
in a different room he's like he just
does not i'm like hey dude can you be a
little careful please be a little
careful you know what's the bug
notice the bumpers when you cancel shows
and stuff so we have to book airbnbs
like a month out so jay books a month
out getting a refund you get 400 refund
but thank god shout out to the guy in
raleigh north carolina because he was a
fan he's like hey man you guys
reschedule i'm not going to charge you
next one's on the house oh wow
which is very rare good for him yeah
thank god it's good business yeah i'll
use him 100 yeah
that's awesome
um tonight though it's gonna be fun
oh dude sam tripley eric griffin calan
myself very special guest that's true
very special it's gonna be good it's
gonna be good i'm excited
uh
that's a dope ass flyer that is a really
good flyer who does your work that's
good [ __ ]
they made me look skinny in that [ __ ]
yeah it sold out there's ten tickets
left this morning that [ __ ] sold out
again you gotta worry the omniground the
media scare you never know man but to
sell out in la tough to do yeah tough
people are having a tough time selling
you play that music chin it's not it's
not no
yeah it's a cool graphic
that's the in-house thick boy artist
exclusive reuben
[Applause]
school's in session
that's gonna be fun all right what else
you got jen
alrighty
let's do this
so chappelle sent this to me yesterday i
guess the uh
man who was on the nirvana cover as a
child had filed that lawsuit and he
missed a trial date so it the entire
case was dismissed he has one more
chance to appeal this and pursue this
lawsuit but as of now he's thrown out
he's a [ __ ] i mean a to sue somebody
based off a historic album he's money he
needs money and thank god
yeah if it worked out you'll be suing
him yeah i bet you wash his hands every
piece so him uh
he said you know what i'm saying dog
can i put my finger in your mouth yeah
[ __ ]
i'm clean though daddy
you might have gone don't trust your
[ __ ] hands
well
so they dismissed it because he didn't
show up because it's not a real case
because
they're just like we don't really so
they weren't [ __ ] with them
because he knows he's fight losing
battle and you gotta pay lower fees too
so
so he's probably gonna not even gonna
fight the problem no nirvana wins again
yeah he's just a dumb duck kurt cobain
from the grave went hey yeah
gotcha got some more of that uh nicotine
you want something you got two patches
three always i go through a count of
days you you have three at one time oh
yeah i go through a can of day shout out
to ryan hey you know what's funny is i
was like man i bet my guns are gonna be
[ __ ] from nicotine stuff like that and
he goes no it's the tobacco that does it
the nicotine does it he goes your gums
are actually really healthy wow yep i
dip every day i go through a can he goes
wow you could never take it the one
thing i get is against her will never be
bad
one thing i always get is i have very
good gums for my age the guy goes you
have great that's good it comes yeah
what does she get jen
so ppr is currently going through some
i guess different marketing strategies
their twitter account on january 3rd
tweeted out not drinking this january
try eating ass oh it's eating ass
january i guess so you'd ask jane and
somebody then respond
somebody responded to that tweet saying
pbr or ass what's the difference and
they responded ask your mom
oh and deleted all these tweets i like
those tweets now that i don't get me if
you're going to be silly and funny i'll
drink that not drinking this january try
eating your ass
that's interesting
or ask what's different ask your mom
that's aggressive though eating ass like
i mean do you like [ __ ] like what ass
is very gender neutral it's acies yeah
acids gender neutral too dude that's
easy to ask girls eat ass yeah
it's a season baby
i'm all for it don't worry about the
hepatitis cause we got you yep just
don't lift my legs like a baby you feel
me
oh you want to trick daddy's sleeping
yeah yeah don't lift my don't lift my
legs like a lamborghini
he's like [ __ ] man he's just disgusting
yeah sweaty he's all [ __ ] man i lift my
legs like a lamborghini door
this is super disgusting i i i just
don't i'm not into that in general i
don't know oh my gosh you're doing it
you're probably gonna need my ass licked
and eaten
like that's it that you eat his ass
that i don't think his yeah good look at
his body ugh
eat that that's a goddamn disaster yeah
his ass is a mess that's a goddamn
disaster mess well
i mean what the things that come out of
there oh
some people are into that
you don't need ass you never eat an ass
i i'm not i've never licked that i have
i haven't
asked you yeah but it's brian
hold on let me give you this straight
right you're worried about licking your
work licking ass but you you're not
worried about washing your hands yeah
yeah you can't be you dude you got to be
with me all the way over here no
hell's angel no i don't germaphobe no
rebel i don't have all the way over
there yeah you do dude why do i have to
be why i cannot not eat ass and then
also not wash your hands yeah i can't no
yeah really wow unreal
i got all i need with the with the
vagine and the mouth i feel sick yeah i
don't need the abs hey this they clean
the ass
let me get down there i mean i i will
and i have
not yeah that knows i've had that nose
over there to the bunny hole and i'm
always like
i'm very uncomfortable yeah yeah yeah i
mean it's a little weird
but i'm a freak then yeah now that i
mean
i have had my
this
worked and it's you've got that old
trumpet worked a little bit
look at the old mud whistle oh
now um the whole thing is
but it's all good
it's all good what else you got jim
i'm a fan of paps though
so jason jerusal got into a fight at the
aria in las vegas because i guess bunch
of guys were trying to like get over
there they called him us they go he said
but they went [ __ ] you [ __ ] and i think
i think just uh sure you'd be like
whatever i'm sure he respects usher but
the hey usher [ __ ] you [ __ ] the [ __ ]
you [ __ ] what set
he was clearly no no no
who's a huge artist huge and why do they
call him they're trying to [ __ ] when
they go hey hey usher [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
then he attacked because he's not a
sherpa but he's not a bodybuilder i
think because he said [ __ ] you [ __ ] as
well yeah it was just clear that they
were trying to cause us because that
sure is a compliment so these guys are
huge [ __ ] yeah and they get dealt
with because he sucks one right in the
[ __ ] oh really let me see that he
gets arrested
oh dude he he's pretty fit fast
watch where he slap him
look at the speed on him though bro he
ran up
knocked his ass down good
is is it weird i like this out of jason
it made me love it
oh yeah it's not a while record cell's
going up those guys thought they could
talk [ __ ] and then dude he came out a
new lovely connected people don't
realize that man you talk [ __ ] to the
i think this helps him i know he's
dealing with some legal [ __ ] now but i
think this actually helps jason derulo
oh he a bad [ __ ] he gets a suit
and all that [ __ ] here or what i don't
think so because they s what are they
gonna assume for
they probably could yeah a bit tough to
sue
well he hit them first
yeah that'd be tough
there is that but you know what you're
right i mean at the end of the day we
all like him and we're all talking yeah
so i'm glad no tupac situation happened
right after you know what i'm saying
with a little shooting yeah a little
shooting because that was that was in
vegas just drew a dance on you there's
something yeah that was sick though what
if he busted a dance move right after
him [ __ ] y'all hoes usher this [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] to the police car and then
went shimon got in the [ __ ] car what
else you got jen
so a man in the uk
bought up a bunch of billboards to
advertise a website where he's trying to
find a girlfriend potentially a wife
because he does not want to be set up
for him save me from an arranged
marriage
a wife.com
there's a website on the website if you
go there's a small video where he does
the intro like hi my name is mal oh he
seems cool he's totally terrible i
believe he's funny for like a group of
religious oh cool now now he's like such
a nice guy what religion is he
based on what he's looking at correct
why you ask me i don't know just a lot
of people don't know um you think i feel
like that was a slam dunk yeah right
some people like that
good yes
good i hope he finds when he sees this
yeah i love this guy i love him yeah his
video seems very yeah he's cool he seems
like a great he comes off authentic in
the video yeah he seems like a genuine
are we allowed to watch it or no
i think you can i mean it's not a clip
of it small it's youtube
i'm a foodie oh he's great i'm religious
i am looking for someone who is working
on her dean i'm open to any ethnicity
but come from a loud punjabi family so
that banter has to be one hundred oh he
might be seeing a love island he's sick
for sure if he's from punjab no the
punjab they also have uh they also have
a lot of muslims there but he's
seriously if he was punjabi i'd say but
i think he's muslim what is that a woman
working on her what i thought
basically like uh he's looking for
another religious woman
oh okay okay he seems awesome he sounds
great i love that guy good luck to that
guy
and over in australia a guy was golfing
when he turns around to look at his bag
and there's a huge crab on it oh those
are no punk either what kind of crap is
that ghost crap i think they call them
ghosts no they're not ghost crabs
they're saying robert i thought it was a
coconut crab but it's a robber crab
i was thinking of a coconut crab those
things crack coconuts oh yeah
so if they get a hold of your peas it's
trouble they eat birds why is your
birthday climb trees dude look at these
on the golf course well that'd be a good
way to torture that's a big [ __ ] crap
would have any video of it i don't know
if they took it out did he [ __ ] up his
golf clubs it's private now
damn he snapped this golf club i don't
um i am signing youtube
they took it down now huh let's see
let's see
no it's not taking me there
now it's unavailable that's all it's
just a crab snap and a golf i saw it
yeah
damn he just went
to your point about antonio brown
he he will play again he it looks like
there are other people he's doing
there's even talk of the bucks kind of
you know being like well yeah isn't that
bad yeah
they need him for the superman need him
you know what yeah as much as he was
having a thing and you know like dude he
just you know
ato yeah so that was probably one of the
uh current events oh
tio said he'll do you say he'll do like
not a whole a season or whatever but
it's like four games he could do like
the four or five games
i just did a podcast with him like two
months ago he's in shape shape really
yeah he's in phenomenal shape how old is
he how are they going to pick him up
probably not
yeah how old is he now
killer though right still in phenomenal
shape
48 holy crap he's 48 40 can't be 48
running route
you can't i don't think so not against
28 year olds right it'd be tough
i mean maybe he still has that speed but
he's so good he did there was a race
where he
tarry killed yeah yeah he raised target
kill and didn't it wasn't bad targets
like the fast man ever was he the one
that snapped the football in the middle
of the field look at the [ __ ]
physique
yeah freaks i mean come on tits
look at the physiques
that's a whole different level mm-hmm
and is he every bit of six-four t-o six
three
tall man
because you're six six six
all right so the news showed a south
korean that defected back to north korea
which is like very rare but apparently
he's a guy that defected from north
korea to south korea
he was able to get past all that stuff
and then started working as a cleaning
guy didn't make that good money this was
tough for him so he actually went back
to north korea well it's not going to
work out for him though is it yeah i
mean i don't know but this is what uh
the new york post says they're going to
kill him
so they said south korea said to please
protect him but we all know what's gonna
if they find him but he was able to
dodge apparently
two million landmines inside they're 150
mile long two and a half mile wide strip
if there's a there's no bigger [ __ ]
than kim jong-un's dad and then kim
jong-un
that whole [ __ ] terrible part of the
world what a horrible way to live
they found they found how about
parasites in his stomach worms that they
see in textbooks that were they found he
was eating he was in the army so he was
eating better than most people they
found whole kernels of dried corn in his
stomach that's what they had to eat
and we just couldn't take it who's that
this guy this dude oh this guy shot
right i thought you told me i know i
think that's a different different guy
this one just happened yeah he's talking
about it differently so he came over
you've seen the one that we saw a video
of him running yeah with the like a heat
sensor or whatever it's crazy to me
though that he went to south korea money
was again went he was like [ __ ] north
korea he was saying this people are
saying because the south korea is so
advanced what they learned in north
korea they couldn't get good jobs so
they would have to just get along
who needs their game boy [ __ ] facts
might be a psyop by north korea they
said that they looked into it and they
they said there was no there's no like
evidence
it could be a [ __ ] spot
propaganda yeah you're right brian yeah
oh i got over i don't like it here i'm
going back nothing's possible anything's
possible oh nobody wanted me to fix
their vcrs i'm headed back you know i've
seen a million times i mean he dodged an
estimated two million landmines
i got two brian called it this guy's a
[ __ ] spy china
i am from korea i was born in korea yeah
there you go interesting you know
i don't trust this [ __ ] spy at all oh
yeah you just
moseyed around the two million landmines
you know you've got a hundred thousand
land mines yeah it got through cars
twice brendan they're in bed
did you tiptoe
and you made it both times interesting
spy
uh so this was a nightmare for hundreds
of uh people on the freeway at the i-95
there was a big like jackknife big rig
and these people were trapped on the
freeway for over 24 hours that's cool
what
was trying to use a car with two kids
freezing temperatures yeah
she had like snackies for them they're
just like luckily these are some [ __ ]
that's not you some people have that
keep when you're in cold weather keep
water snacks blankets snacks yeah oh
yeah
think about how thirsty you are there's
no water in california you better have
that stuff yeah did they go and
feed them yeah so there was help that
came out too to try to like pull them
you know so let's get that big rig off
of there huh
also this is why i'm not touring in
january because going the east coasters
haven't been in two years it's just not
worth it right now well utah has been
mighty cold
utah is cold cold cold cold it's cold
and they got some snow storms
you'll be all right though because you
stay right across the street no i stayed
with my mommy and daddy oh i've been to
your mommy's daddy to my mommy and daddy
the picture of you and your sister on
the fridge in the private jet and my dad
said my dad said uh my house has just
had a valuation and
it it he gave me a number and i said
sell that i said my your daughter my
sister talks behind your back yeah and i
think it's my house [ __ ] that's my house
give me the house and then did you kill
yourself i'm your dad i'm your son yeah
i've been there for your only son i'm
the oldest
give me the [ __ ] house what do you
say and then i will corrode him i will
get that the number he gave me uh i
would take my own father's life and i
love him it's nice in there i'll kill
him for you i need money i've had a
tough couple of years need some money
does daddy know the tough years or no of
course he knows he's tough here like my
ear though when when i was cool
does he care though no my dad the best
my dad goes how you doing i go listen
the answer is always terrible just so
you know so let's talk ask me any other
question he goes good good and i was
telling him i was what was mean one time
yeah he goes like this is so good he
goes well
i guess you got to just keep kicking the
sandbag down the [ __ ] road that was
all we need more people like your dad
though that yeah you know
how about my you know my dentist nothing
about what i do a problem in the studio
you and your friends like recording here
and then i go and i go and i go this way
do fire and then can i go and brian's
back full time thank god he goes what
happened to brian
[Laughter]
i swear to god i go you serious he goes
when i got sick yeah yeah you got sick
daddy that's it
you have no idea what happened
jake
nobody told you what i've been through
he goes no why don't we go what do you
call video
hey covet man yeah i didn't talk to you
really long time
after that we drove the car dead silence
how do you not know oh jesus christ well
you know listen people have their own
lives yeah that's all it is
tarella ones
all right remember these brothers
who wow these guys are famous for their
crazy surgical procedures to their face
that make them look like really i don't
know their cheekbones are crazy crazy
high what the [ __ ] is what looks like a
fun house mirror their teeth you've seen
them before
they were born in a castle and they did
the surgery and then they just they're
twins that were really famous because of
how they looked after their surgeries
but then some crypto company put them
into a meme and they became this big
thing and then they made money yeah but
they were born in a castle so i don't
think they need money there's a weird
because they live in the castle the
whole time like a boat and all that [ __ ]
now they're much they're probably in
their 60s i can they look very old well
i mean this is i know where they're at
now
they're what's feed under oh yeah they
passed away right just passed away it's
the only reason you could be bringing
this up yeah it can't be because they're
full yeah i don't know
what it says in my life
block letters oh 72 passed away days of
our
lives six days apart they refuse to get
back they said refuse but they just
didn't get it i don't know if they
refuse by the way though they're 72 they
look pretty good with 72 even though
they look like human cats they look
crazy yeah they look [ __ ] insane they
look like you're looking at them
they do
i bet they're the ones who scam me
guarantee you guys
i bet the scammer was going to send
those two they're not and you wouldn't
be allergic to no i would be able to and
they'll just sit around like now
i'll keep both of them you want to sauce
our milk old boys want a little sauce or
milk
and then yeah hell yeah but they they
passed huh yeah yeah they they're good
pasta so elizabeth holmes legal experts
are saying that she's going to get uh
likely a two digit year sentence who is
she she's the one that started the
theranos theranose yeah that blood
testing thing oh yeah she it was all it
was all yeah and she had she made her
voice yeah artificially deep yeah she's
a good and she dressed like steve steven
jobs that's right um
and it turns out she was i was all one
big fan she finessed everybody and uh
guilty of four hours
yeah she's gone and the germans there's
family in washington d.c
i might even
know that my family my family might know
the family i don't know there's a rumor
and uh it's a tough one but jurors are
saying that it was really hard to to try
to send this first because she was so
nice and like she's a pleasure to be
she's a con artist i know that's what
she's they're charming they have
charisma so does you know what us does
serial killers
look she
she duped a whole bunch of people and if
you're going to do how much money did
she give eight billion dollars the
company was valued at eight billion
billion dollars
a lot of people put their money into it
she had she had henry kissinger and
george schultz the former secretary of
state
on her board etc
and she
she ran this company and basically was
was
making she actually said she used
stationery with pfizer on it and said
pfizer was was oh wow one of the people
that vouched for it it was all [ __ ]
now i don't know
i remember she went on a date and these
huge interviews and stuff but there are
people that think that she dressed like
steve jobs yeah and it's like i'll tell
you what she's gonna get her ass licked
in uh prison though they'll do that
there man yeah they get bored she'll
probably do 10.
yeah of heart i don't like seeing people
like this do 30 years but i do think she
needs to do time you know what she
should do
i think she do two years a hard two
years in like pelican well do you see
the problem with during two years bubba
is that you don't have enough then you
then what happens when you have real
fraud like this like enron like this
doing a lot of money they keep doing it
you got to make an example you're right
it's such a [ __ ] you and i wouldn't be
good at this we wouldn't be good
yeah but you i don't like your eyes
though that's why she's got pretty eyes
she's such a phony though no she's she
looks a [ __ ] narcissist she looks
crazy she's just gonna look like she got
pretty eyes creeped me out your whole
life your whole life see you later
you're going away for at least 10 years
i hope it's worth it enjoy those [ __ ] no
more turtlenecks [ __ ] you know she's in
jail right now oh yeah they're appealing
but she's in jail it's crazy how i could
get that far with all of this how long
did she get huh how long of a run i
don't know for a while oh she she had a
run for what is it ten years i don't
know how i do what that was
and what exactly
it's like that dude in uh
he he put together something he told
everyone that he has a deal
by the way it was started in 2003 19
year old elizabeth holmes
it peaked in 2014 resulting in a 10
billion evaluation dude you should have
sold that thing for five billion
billionaires and moved to thailand
that's right
yeah no more turtlenecks is liz's home
still a billionaire
the answer is no
yeah the government takes all that money
wow it's insane went that far
no one did any background horseshit
she's hilarious it's unbelievable
all right so john stewart is saying jk
rowling is an auntie basically saying
she's anti-semitic because of the goblin
characters in harry potter and also pete
davidson kind of made a joke about it
before as well do you know the goblin
characters in uh no no no i'm 38. that's
very long noses
oh they're saying those are jewish yeah
yeah yeah yeah well do all the
characters look like that in this no but
they all look all there's a bunch of
different characters just the ones good
at much like this yeah the bankers look
like this yeah no no other character
that's uh i don't remember watching did
you ever see do you ever see passion of
the christ with mel gibson of course i
know of it well where you see the the
guy throw these shackles and he's got a
prosthetic nose it's a giant like nose
so they're trying to insinuate that he's
sort of jewish then right
that's what people are saying
yeah
so so if you have to go back to nazi
propaganda the nazis if you look at
their posters they call them devils that
is exactly what they look upside down
rats and they looked like that they had
these giant noses they were scary yeah
they're like a lot of children during
the blood chart they would sleep upside
down they had these caves horrible and
that that's that right there is uh i can
see i can see a problem with that yeah
do you want to see pizza real quick sure
short i love pete i mean what's wrong
with her colin the woods are controlled
by centaurs the schools are run by
wizards and ghosts but who controls the
banks
jews obviously
giant knows jew goblins
and i can say that because as you can
see i'm half goblin
he's all laughing he's great he's great
what a sweetheart yeah the best
i don't know what else you got to do
that's it that's pretty much all right
those are good man cool well guys we did
it again huh you have to slowly see
you're going to be staying with daddy
sure in the full the whole time you're
there you're going to try and convince
them to give you the house i'm staying
with my mommy and daddy and i'm going to
try to get the passwords to his [ __ ]
computer and i'm going to get into that
will i'm going to change some [ __ ] up
and then and then they call
he's all boosted up well well for uh we
rescheduled rally so sorry guys i'm
shutting it down for january i'll be
doing sets all around los angeles i have
a show tonight the improv sold out and
then tuesday night at the comedy store
and uh comedy store belly room and then
also another show in the main room at
the improv that's next tuesday i think
it's the 11th and the only thing on the
books right now we're rescheduling that
so march 24th through the 26th is
chicago and that's it all right love you
guys sign up for supercast if you want
to listen to me and brian break down my
fights the classic cowbest fight
companion the next fight companion is
january 22nd with christa stefano
crystalia brian kellen myself for the
francis gano sierra gone fight we have a
food truck coming next week for your ass
uh tune in to thick boy
boom yeah and then february 25th through
26th i'll be the comedy club of kansas
city so i won't be able to do sacramento
with you okay
love you guys
love ya